notre écoute et heureusement que vous
êtes venu ça ne peut plus durer il faut
que vous président de la fête annuelle
de l'île aux enfants vous agissiez avec
aimé notre cher ami tout d'abord calmez
vous je n'ai pas eu l'honneur de vous
saluer ce que je déplore profondément
bonjour ma très chère amie excusez moi
mais c'est utile d'abord calmer vos
chers amis rien n'est pas d'avoir une
telle urgence donnez moi votre bras nous
allons faire quelques pas ensemble vous
voulez cela me fera le plus grand bien
justement c'est impossible
vous n'êtes pas malade ou moins me
regarder seulement devant vous monsieur
du snad d'en haut mais mais qui a fait
ça vous ne devinez pas regarder au fond
du jardin
voilà on celui ci est vraiment très beau
celui là aussi splendide
j'adore recevoir des dessins écoutez
nous allons essayer d'aller le rejoindre
oui mais alors faites bien attention je
marchais derrière moi mais pourquoi
fait-il cela le shérif
mais vous savez que les enfants envoient
beaucoup des saints à kazim hier on fait
attention
j'en reçois aussi d'ailleurs ah bon
c'est étrangement jamais reçu qu'un ou
deux enfin pas ça alors il en a reçu des
centaines oui mais mais pourquoi les
pauses t-il sur le sol
attention attention votre pied postée
sur le sol c'est bien parce que les murs
de sa chambre sont entièrement tapissé
et qu'il ne veut pas les maîtres ni dans
une malle ni dans une armoire
il faut qu'il soit présent à chaque
instant mais pourquoi n'y at on pas dit
que la pluie pouvait les habits mis par
exemple enfin voyons messieurs du snop
vous savez fort bien que le climat
magique de l'île aux enfants fait qu'il
y fait toujours beau ah oui c'est vrai
sus bête dans l'est l'otan font c'est
tous les jours le printemps vous jamais
oublier aussi les mamans sert à manger
nous avons imaginé fermement ne vous
inquiétez pas ne soyez pas trop sévère
quand même no no no casimir au monsieur
du snarr vous êtes venus voir les
dessins mont-joli c'est vraiment gentil
de la voir annexe ça
ils sont vraiment oui et je le vois que
je sais je sais vous allez moi vous me
reprochez nous ne pas vous montrer mes
dessins et de parler on a exactement
nous nous était venu avec nous et julie
pour moi pour ça va je ne juge je ne
perds pas tant je voulais montrer
regardez celui là est de 1 jean pierre
audy d'un merveilleux
l'idée russe est que pensez vous de
celui ci augmente c'est nathalie qu'il a
faits auxquels coloriste l'émotion
quelle finesse par l'église et
merveilles la wii or ils sont admirables
quasi les appareils sont très très bon
maintenant laisse moi je les admire et
je les ai pas le plus à casimir tu as un
véritablement de petits c d'heure n'est
ce pas je serais vraiment malheureux de
les laisser dans un placard se disent
nos amis parce que vous aviez promis
d'en parler oui mais ce n'est pas facile
voyez mais du coup ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça pardon mais qu'est ce
qui ne peut pas continuer comme ça moi
je dis stop
vous n'avez pas me demander au moins de
ramasser tous mes dessins je serais trop
triste
eh bien eh bien voilà ce qui ne veut pas
durer et semir tu as lequel trop petit
pour afficher des dessins aux six mois
mais se disloque
en tant que président de la fête de
l'île aux enfants je décide la création
du musée que dis bravo monsieur 10,9
merci alors et écoute en continu
oui mais à une condition laquelle et
bien c'est quand vous est taillée au
milieu du musée un grand lit pivotant de
façon que je puisse regarder tous mes
dessins semblent fatigués d'accord allez
nous allons voir l'emplacement du musée
quasi nié tout formidable tu viens julie
non non je reste pour ranger les
chefs-d'oeuvre du futur musée casimir
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
je voudrais faire
le tri
non
j'y vois les garçons
casimir show de sa chanson
[Musique]
françois
mais je l'aurais mieux pas si j'avais
joué à fond l'âge
mieux peu si j'étais un enfant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cela
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
dans le kiosque
les poupées
on l'est
écoliers
couleur cerise
à papillons passe ton
ainsi sur
à
utile
mais je m'en fais mieux pas si je
faisais la fin
si j'étais un enfant
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]